♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
LARRY DAVID: Cheryl.
CHERYL HINES:
The difference between reality
and on the show as Cheryl David,
I'm not as entertained
by what's going on.
There was an episode where
we were renewing our vows.
I thought we were gonna
stay together
during the afterlife.
I didn't know
we went into eternity together.
It carries over!
HINES: So, I think in real-life
I would be like,
"You're an idiot."
But, Cheryl David
was not thrilled.
JB SMOOVE:
There's a lot of Leon in JB.
But there's no JB in Leon.
Leon don't know how
to compose himself.
(SCREAMS)
Leon's not gonna cross
his fucking right leg
over his left leg.
Leon-- He dresses shabby.
First of all,
we don't dress alike at all.
Well, good afternoon,
General Petraeus.
-John Varvatos.
-LARRY: Really?
His entire fall collection...
-Is that right? Camouflage?
-...is camouflage.
I wish that I was as comfortable
in my anger as she is.
And I wish that I was able
to just walk around
telling everybody
to go fuck themselves.
-Get the fuck out of here,
all right?
-Okay.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪